Speaker 1: Welcome back, everybody.
A lot to get to today, I think it is really
time for the FBI to act and formally start
investigating if they have not already Trumpy
in Congressman Madison Catherines, completely
unhinged and outrageous rant about armed citizens
taking over the U.S. government and using
as an analogy how the Viet Cong acted during
the Vietnam War against American troops.
And just every layer of this is trash.
This is a sitting congressman.
He's part of this Trumpy and trio, Lauren
Bobert, Marjorie Taylor Green and him, Madison
Cawthorn.
This is sort of like a new breed of elected
official, completely devoid even of a pretense
of caring about policy.
They just run offices based on tweets, memes,
political stunts and interviews on right wing
media.
There's their overt in that they don't even
pretend to be about policy.
This political stunt should really have some
consequences.
Last week, Cawthorn, who, by the way, represents
North Carolina, I wrongly said a couple of
weeks ago he represents South Carolina.
Madison Calthorpe Katharyn, representing North
Carolina in the House, was being interviewed
by Newsmax host Chris Saucedo.
Now, Chris Saucedo has had me on his radio
show.
You can find how that went.
There's a clip on my YouTube channel.
And Cawthorn specifically said about those
who say that having small arms, meaning firearms,
wouldn't be useful in overthrowing the government
if the government were to become tyrannical.
He says, no, no, no, it is possible.
Look at how the Viet Cong handled the United
States Marines and the United States Army
during the Vietnam War.
Take a look at this.
Speaker 3: You didn't see that what I'm making
allusion to, but he's asked I think it was
Senator Kennedy who asked him define an assault
weapon.
And he sat there and said, I can't define
an assault weapon yet.
They want to take something called an assault
weapon, which you and I both know doesn't
exist.
They want to take it away from us.
So doesn't, you know, basically undermine.
Go ahead.
Yeah, well, you know, I actually saw him walk,
try and walk that back and say, well, you
know what, the definition of assault weapons,
anything that shoots a semiautomatic rounds,
something that you don't you can pull the
trigger multiple times without having to reload
and it shoots.
That is basically every single modern sporting
rifle in the United States of America.
But let me tell you, this is not right for
supporting the Second Amendment.
It's a tyrannical government ever wants to
rise up.
We can stop them.
And if anybody ever wants to say, oh, well,
you know what?
Citizens with a few small arms fire would
never be able to stop the federal government.
I absolutely disagree.
Ask the Viet Cong how they handle the Marines
and the Army in Vietnam.
Speaker 1: Now, I really am struggling with
what is the most absurd and disgusting part
of this.
It's hard to figure out because there's so
much going on.
I mean, the whole clip is 60 seconds.
He's only talking four part of it.
And there's just so much nuttiness there.
First of all, again, the idea of of the Second
Amendment's purpose being for the overthrow
of a potentially tyrannical government as
the most important thing the Second Amendment
is meant for.
That's just wrong and that's disgusting.
That's number one.
Secondly, he keeps raising the Viet Cong,
the Viet Cong, the Viet Cong, which killed
endless American members of the military during
the Vietnam War.
He raises that as the model of armed citizen
uprising against our government.
Vietnam veterans are not going to like that,
first and foremost.
But it's most importantly a historically really
stupid analogy to make, because, first of
all, the reason the Viet Cong was as effective
as it was at killing Americans was the Americans
came from across the world and were fighting
in Vietnam.
There is simply no analogy to a hypothetical
Cawthorn force of right wingers with guns
trying to fight the U.S. Army on U.S. soil.
It's such an absurd comparison that it's hard
to take seriously.
But sadly, lots of the people who would be
ignorant enough to vote for this guy probably
hear it and say, yeah, that makes a lot of
sense.
And then the other aspect of this that's absurd
is that even when fighting the U.S. Army,
which had traveled across the world, remember
during the Vietnam War, the Viet Cong wasn't
able to win anything or control anything.
They were able to wreak such havoc that they
made the war really expensive and difficult
for the United States to continue fighting.
The Viet Cong wasn't even winning on their
own soil, and it was their own soil, after
all.
And the U.S. military was halfway across the
world.
So it's such an ignorant and and ignorant
of history analogy.
And comparison, but too many right wingers
hear this and they think, Madison Cawthorn,
he knows history.
What an amazing young man.
That's amazing.
What a smart guy.
The guy's a fool.
And these comments are so borderline unhinged,
it doesn't seem out of line to me that the
FBI would look at whether people are being
radicalized and getting involved in specific
actions involving guns as a result of the
nonsense that this guy is saying.
It's it's really an indictment against another
one.
I mean, these are exhausting.
It's one after the other.
It's another indictment on the intelligence
and understanding of how the world works of
such a huge portion of the American electorate.
And as I've said before, if you overestimate
the intelligence of the American electorate,
you are almost certain to be disappointed.
The biggest example of that, of course, is
Donald Trump's 2016 run for president of the
United States